some people want to keep them i'm not
comfortable with taking my mask off
in crowded places while others are ready
to say goodbye to them yes definitely
ready to take off that mask masks have
become a staple for most people over the
last two years but as mandates and
restrictions lift people are starting to
feel more comfortable with the idea of
going mask less again we've come a long
way and we've mostly been
fully vaccinated there's still a divide
amongst canadians if they're ready to
lose them an angus reits study found 36
percent of canadians feel mass mandates
are being lifted too fast while 22
percent say it's not happening fast
enough experts say you may want to throw
away the masks but you may be better off
holding on to them for a little bit
longer you know just because we want it
to be over we are not in charge the
virus is in charge john baudish is a
research chair in immunology and aging
she says despite more than 80 percent of
eligible canadians being double
vaccinated it's not enough there's
enough people who've only had two doses
and of course enough children who either
aren't eligible for vaccination because
they're too young or they've only had
two doses but infectious diseases
physician suman chakrabarti says it's a
good time to remove mask mandates since
we've made a lot of progress with
vaccines it is mitigating it is very
much reducing the risk of severe disease
in the highest risk people yes it's true
that many children are not yet
vaccinated but the one thing that's
important to note is that children
especially healthy ones have an
extremely low risk of severe disease
chakrabarty says we also need to take
other factors into account which could
have a negative impact whether it's
mental health whether it's non-coded
related matters the economy people's
livelihoods all these things
have been impacted severely
another one is our child's education but
chakrabarty and baudish both agree
people should continue wearing masks if
that makes them feel more comfortable
regardless of mandates charming somani
global news